Die illegale elfenbein jägerei hat drastische folgen durch die wilderei kommen mittlerweile ein drittel der afrikanischen elefanten ohne
Stoßzähne auf der welt denn die nachfrage nach elfenbein in asien ist groß hier denkmal unsinnigerweise immer noch dass die zu pulver
Zerriebenen horner eine art wunder medizin gegen fieber und so weiter sind ein krasses und trauriges beispiel dafür
Wie wir menschen in der evolution herumpfuschen können ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts, so
herzlich willkommen bei pixum science and fiction
Und wie er zum whatsapp und den anderen messengern kommt und direkt kontakt mit mir aufnehmen können das erfahrt, am ende
Des videos das ist wirklich ein schlimmer irrglaube der von 2007 bis 2014 alleine
144000 afrikanische elefanten das leben gekostet hat die mehrheit der chinesen weiß tatsächlich nicht das elfenbein von
Getöteten elefanten stamm viele asiaten denken die elefanten hörner würden den tieren abfallen wie bei kindern die milchzähne
ausfallen hinzu kommt dass das horn das zu pulver vertrieben wird noch immer eine entscheidende rolle in der chinesischen medizin
spielt aber auch in vietnam wird es von vielen vor allem reichen leuten genutzt beispielsweise als anti kater mittel oder als
Aufputz strobe dabei besteht es hauptsächlich, aus keratin
Genau wie unsere fuß oder fingernägel hier also doch die stoßzähne erfüllen wichtige funktionen für die elefanten sind quasi die oberen schneidezähne
Die im ersten lebensjahr die milchzähne
des elefantenbabys ersetzen fanden können mit ihrer hilfe beispielsweise
Die rinde von bäumen schaben nach wasser oder wurzeln graben und natürlich gegen andere elefanten kämpfen, im laufe
des elefanten lebens werden die stoßzähne immer länger und dicker und dennoch gilt elfenbein in asien als
luxusprodukt und wird bei schwarzmarkt preisen von bis zu 50 euro pro gramm gehandelt
naturschutzorganisationen den seit jahren gegen diesen irrglauben und das unwissen der menschen an aber dennoch hat wilderei spuren hinterlassen in mosambik
Waren bis 1992 fast 90 prozent der tiere ausgerottet
Bei
Denen die überlebt haben und sie vermehren konnten kommen nun aber ein drittel der elefanten ohne stoßzähne auf die welt und das liegt an dem
evolutionären druck unterschiedliche forschungsgruppen konnten verstärkt feststellen dass immer mehr elefanten eben ohne die
veranlagung für stoßzähne geboren werden denn weil besonders diejenigen unter ihnen die große stoßzähne tragen gejagt und getötet werden
können sich diese elefanten nicht mehr fortpflanzen dafür aber diejenigen die
Kleine stoßzähne haben oder gar keine und dieses merkmal
Geben sie dann auch an ihre nachkommen weiter und das obwohl die wilderei in mosambik mittlerweile ganz gut unter kontrolle
Gebracht werden konnte und sich die elefantenpopulation erholen konnte denn auch nach
Dem ende des bürgerkriegs 1992 sind es 30 prozent der weiblichen elefanten die ohne
Stoßzähne zur welt kommt und dieses phänomen ist nicht nur in mosambik
sondern auch in anderen ländern zu beobachten und das hat fatale folgen für die entwicklung der gesamten elefantenpopulation
denn studien zeigen dass die großen elefanten die meist auch die größeren stoßzähne tragen normalerweise
deutlich mehr kälber zeugen sie werden bei der fortpflanzung von weiblichen elefanten
eigentlich bevorzugt denn sie tragen wohl besonders gute gene zum überleben in sich so lange sie nicht gejagt werden
natürlich ein trauriges und krasses beispiel also für menschen
gemacht der evolution und darauf sollten wir als alles andere als stolz sein ein weiteres beispiel dafür ist übrigens die intensive selektive fischerei
Nicht nur dass die weltmeere schon bald leer gefischt sein könnten
forschungsteams haben schon vor einiger zeit festgestellt dass dadurch nicht nur die anzahl der fische sondern auch ihre
körpergröße und ihre fortpflanzungsfähigkeit
schrumpft auch hier also der mensch als evolution faktor der vor allem die starke fischten fischarten stark und schnell
beeinträchtigt die populationen können sich nur sehr langsam erholen weil immer kleinere und weniger
fruchtbare fische überleben die kabbala bestände von neuseeland beispielsweise haben so den druck ihrer
Energie viel früher in die fortpflanzung zu stecken als normalerweise über lebende fische werden genetisch bedingt also
früher geschlechtsreif und bleiben so auch kleiner hier ist das bekannte darwin prinzip der evolution
nachdem die stärksten überleben also tatsächlich umgekehrt die besten überlebenschancen haben die kleinen und schwachen ja
manche forschungsziel sind da der ansicht dass diese entwicklung durch die elfenbein jagd und die fischerei
Möglicherweise bereits unumkehrbar sind und der grund dafür sind wir menschen nicht umsonst gibt es einige
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler die die folgen des menschlichen verhaltens und handels mit den fünf größten massensterben der erdgeschichte
Vergleichen ja wenn er als erstes neues zur evolution und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp oder den anderen
messengern wie instagram facebook oder telegramm dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
Täglich garantieren ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von links zum mitmachen und mitbestimmen
Was hier bei pixum passiert und zur begrüßung?
habe ich ein kleines goodie für euch einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter dafür auch draufklicken
Evolutionstheorie endgültig bestätigt kreationisten auf verlorenen posten ja so ist es ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran